here with more is former secretary of
state mike pompeo uh mr secretary good
to see you first let me get your
reaction to president zielinski today
and i like the reagan model and i like
the trump model uh am i wrong in my
analysis uh do you have a better idea
no sean i think that's right those those
two models were very consistent they
were they were speak pretty softly but
when it was time to swing into action
you did it with full force you weren't
late you weren't behind you weren't slow
you were protecting america's interest
everywhere you went in your in your
opening you talked about the moral
imperative to do this i think president
zielinski talked about that eloquently
today but there's an important american
set of interests here as well that we
need not forget right the american
economy is going to be impacted by this
fertilizer food oil and gas all going to
be more expensive because the
administration put climate change ahead
of protecting sovereignty and freedom in
this place i think you have it right we
we should be providing all the tools
that the ukrainian people need to defend
themselves we have them the europeans
have them they can do an awful lot more
too but instead president biden has been
behind he's allowed vladimir putin to
dictate the pace and the response um
he's allowed he's allowed vladimir putin
to to dominate how we think about the
structure of what's taking place here
and we can do better than this americans
deserve it the ukrainian people deserve
it as well and i think president
zielinski spoke to that very very nicely
today
why when poland wanted to give these
migs to um ukraine
the person that vetoed that idea was joe
biden it went right to him why why
wouldn't he say the poem do whatever you
think is right
it's hard to explain sean why he would
take the posture that said that it was a
european country one to provide weapon
systems that belong to that european
country to give to their european friend
and partner the ukrainians that
president biden would say step in and
say no we're not going to let that
happen
i it's hard to also explain sean why
we're second guessing what zolinski says
he needs to defend himself he has
demonstrated his military leaders have
demonstrated their capability to defend
against
a russian military that we thought was
really capable if they're asking for
certain tools we ought to do our best to
give them to them and we shouldn't wait
we are months behind i know this war's
nominally only been going on for a
handful of weeks but we've known for
months that this was in the offing and
we should have been stacking these
weapons javelins missiles stingers all
the things that the ukrainians need to
defend themselves for months and months
and months instead we're going to get
them to them i hope we get them to them
fast and in a serious way
one of the things that we got to keep in
mind as we see hostilities with north
korea heating up in their icbm testing
uh doesn't always work out well for them
then we have this iranian deal now back
on the table which seems to me almost
seems dramatically worse than the first
bad deal that they did
i guess joe wants to import oil from
iran and
i guess joe might be okay with vladimir
putin building a nuclear facility for
the iranians and
i guess joe wants to import oil from
venezuela and iran those are things that
i can't really comprehend uh mr
secretary but you were in taiwan
recently but also you know president xi
he's watching all of this what is he
thinking tonight and what is taiwan
thinking tonight
i was just in taiwan i can tell you what
the taiwanese people are thinking
they're thinking that being stuck in the
middle
uh without an american set of leaders
that are prepared to assist you when a
superpower a big nation comes to attack
you they're very concerned it puts them
on edge i think xi xingpings watch this
too and while i've seen the
demonstration applauding saying boy we
have european unity that unity came only
after an enormous amount of destruction
inside of ukraine that continues to this
day i think taiwan is certainly watching
that i'm confident that the xi jinping's
not only watching what's going on
in ukraine today but he's watching us
sit at a table in vienna while the
russians are killing innocent women and
children we're sitting on the same side
of the negotiating table with the
russians about to hand iran a clear
pathway to getting russian weapons
systems it sounds like we've let the
russians
purchase or excuse me sell
equipment to the iranians as part of
this deal as well i mean sean this is
this is unexplainable it is it is a
level of appeasement that we haven't
seen in the united states in an awfully
long time and it is dangerous not only
for the taiwanese not only for the
ukrainians but it's dangerous for the
united states of america to watch bad
guys roll the west
and when you watch the
the communist chinese fly their fighter
jets over taiwan air space to the degree
that they have and they talk about
reunification to the extent that they
have
um it seems pretty clear to me that
they're they have their own territorial
ambitions and they're probably soon
gonna follow through on them i hope i'm
wrong mr secretary but i don't think i
am
sean i hope you're wrong too uh whether
you're wrong or not we'll depend an
awful lot on how the united states
responds how the japanese the
australians the south koreans respond if
if we do this well i promise you the
taiwanese people are very capable and
they're prepared to fight the same way
you've seen the ukrainians fight they
can change the calculus for xi xingping
they can make this cost extraordinary
for him but we can't wait we can't wait
until
he's got ships at the ships at sea and
airplanes in the air and a blockade
established to say oh goodness now we're
going to gather it uh gather it
someplace and decide what we're gonna do
we should be preparing the taiwanese
with all the tools they tell us they
need and make sure that xi jinping
understands that we are serious when he
when he raises the specter as he did
just this past week when the chinese
talk about a the the big price that the
united states will pay for sending
equipment to taiwan he's talking about
the use of nuclear weapons too we cannot
allow tyrants to threaten nuclear
weapons to engage in coercive behavior
it didn't happen for four years in our
administration we shouldn't let it
happen now
i hope they're listening secretary of
state mike pompeo we do need the adults
back in power that would be really
helpful thank you for being with us hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else